Here are three ways to create urgency in
your copywriting that almost feels
unethical to make people buy. So, check
this out. Everything you want to sell
needs to be around a deadline. And
deadlines are actually generous. They're
generous because people are undecisive
whether they should buy or not buy. And
giving them a deadline forces them to
make a decision whether it is to buy or
not to buy by a certain time. So, it is
generous and helpful especially if you
do it right. And the best ways to do a
deadline that actually make more people
buy than not is one, you could do a
deadline that has a price increase.
Okay? So after X date, the price of this
product goes up. One of my favorite ways
to do a deadline. Now, one of the most
common ones is a price decrease. Okay,
for the next 48 hours, we're doing 25%
off. I like this one the least because
it gets people used to discounted prices
and it actually devalues your brand. So,
I put it second. But third, the last one
is a timed bonus. This is actually my
favorite of all of them because it's
going to cost you less than giving away
certain dollars and it's going to get
them more bought into your brand. So,
you could say something like when you
buy X, you also get Y for a limited
time. And so that way they get like a
two for one type thing. If the bonus why
is actually valuable, this is by far one
of the best needle movers. This one is
your second. And I would stay clear away
from this using it too often, but it
still works.